one comedian plus one joint plus
research equals stone size I'm Matt and
I'm Dave and we are stoned so it all
starts out right with air air
it all starts out out here and it needs
to get in here right yes how do we do it
two holes you talk about the first hole
but also local start to roll great okay
so my first hole is actually the nose
holes it's actually the best way for you
to breathe there are many reasons why
but most limits like inside your body
it's like a wet place and the nose
moistens the air that you're taking in
your nut nose hairs which matt has a
thousand filters like bacteria like
random things that might be in the air
that your lungs don't want to breathe
and then there's the mouth classic mouth
alright though there's the mouth you
know we all know where we all love
sometimes she shouldn't blab so as nice
a lady she's fun but not all the time
okay
at the back we have the uvula and also
the epiglottis which is at the back of
your throat and also the camara stage
epiglottis epiglottis you know where is
epiglottis she does the 11 o'clock
number she does the 11 number but miss
epiglottis is also the one who's the
bouncer up yeah fingers miss epiglottis
is telling you what list you are on yes
honey are you food are you air and if
you have food are you going to the
esophagus or if you are air very
important and you go to the larynx yes
yes this larynx which is going waste
boxes that's weight these are where your
vocal cords are yeah and actually when
you exhale it's the the rapid motion of
these cords in your voice box and your
larynx that's what makes sound so what
makes you able to sing and that's where
that's where it comes from magic how
thinking about how beautiful that is
that's where sound comes from well so
I'll just say that sentence that's where
sound
so we're in the trachea and it's hard
it's hard like a hose the trachea is
hard you I mean like at all times I can
say my I'm hard because if I have a
trachea yeah so whenever anyone tells
you I'm hard just think they might be
talking about their trachea yes
tracheas harvest has a lot of cartilage
and this takes the air down and breaks
into two separate the bronchi bronchus
so it's one is bronchus - yes absolutely
and then that further breaks down into
the bronc kills from Kiehl's are like
where things get microscopic because now
we are in the lungs baby and that means
we are ready to countering LVO lies and
alveoli x' are where it really goes down
they look like grapes a lot like wet
there is 700 million of them so many 700
million no not even so many there's 700
million which is so many that is so many
you really don't want your alveoli x' to
be dry no it needs to be wet they need
to be really wet like if I get my
healthy ole eyes and they're dry I'm
actually just gonna send it back because
the I ordered these alveoli x' webs so
just take it off the Chad just take it
off the check I don't want anything else
and that's I'm not gonna be ordering
anything because we already taken off
the check because I think everyone's
good yeah we've got a food already I'll
figure it out
I'll figure it out but these were red
blood cells are where the swap occurs
the swap occurred yes honey it's an uber
driver if she's dropping off yes and she
saying baby star rating please good bye
thank you
now you're going they're going with a
lifestyle and Golu throughout the body
throughout the body immediately arms
truly every part of your body every part
yes
co2 however she gotta go she's gotta go
and they gotta go way uptown oh you're
going up and out through one of my two
holes on the way out all the co2 is
taken you exhale and you've just
breathed and you know you do it over
20,000 times a day yes actually you do
it over 20,000 times today that's real
that is a real number but it's yeah
20,000 did you know this fact if you
took the lungs and smushed it out that
literally it would be 27 feet by 27 feet
nine meters by nine meters cuz we're in
Canada meters to make it more
international for ya and that was the
respiratory system what did you guys
think I thought it was good I thought it
was amazing I thought it was really good
I thought that I thought was Slade what
can I say something came in here not
knowing one thing about it I knew I had
lungs all right I I had heard the rumors
that I had had lungs but we never lie
about this thought about it for realsies
but it's amazing it's like until I see
that the world is round right it's flat
but I mean for me it's flat I'm sorry
that's just my experience and today the
world is round again again yeah and also
like amazing cuz like that's how you get
high and where you are high as hell yeah
yeah like where's our sushi thank you
for watching our new series inspired by
the fact that now weed is illegal in
Canada and thank you to Matt and Dave
for being hilarious and being in our
video if you want to follow them up with
their links in the description below we
have a bunch of other episodes coming
but we want to know what other comedians
or episode concepts you'd like to see
and think would be funny we appreciate
you letting us try something new give us
your comments you know inspiration let
us know how we can build this together
and make sure you're subscribed for more
stoned science